Traduttore: Patrizia C Romeo Tomasini
Revisore: Elena Montrasio
(Musica)
La mia vita oggi ha bisogno di questo.
Vi racconter˜ò, tra poco,
di come ho capito, innanzitutto una cosa,
quando feci la mia scelta.
Forse, è   racchiusa in una frase:
"Non amo meno gli uomini
ma più la Natura".
Magari non erano queste
le parole esatte che avevo in mente
ma certo, ne rimasi incantata
quando le vidi scritte, nere su bianco,
da una penna che non era la mia.
Sono infatti i versi del poeta Byron.
Da allora sono la mia guida.
Ero poco più  che una bambina,
ma legittimano,
nel modo pi ù tecnico della parola,
la mia esistenza in questo mondo
e  ci˜ò che ho deciso di fare,
inclusa la mia scelta recente
più  drastica.
Da quattro anni passo
la maggior parte della mia vita
a bordo di una nave di Sea Shepherd.
È un'organizzazione internazionale
che si occupa di oceani.
La Bob Barker  è stata la mia casa
per molti mesi.
Io sono profondamente convinta
che sia fondamentale
assumersi la responsabilitˆà
di operare una scelta
per salvare il futuro.
Certo è  pi ù facile non sapere,
cambiare canale, voltare pagina,
perchéŽ sapere implica scegliere.
E a volte le scelte si scontrano
con i piaceri personali, le abitudini.
Richiedono rinunce e sacrifici.
Io ho fatto la mia scelta
e l'incontro con Sea Shepherd,
peraltro del tutto casuale,
fu amore a prima vista
per quell'azione diretta
in difesa dell'ambiente e degli animali
che fa la differenza
e di cui avevo bisogno.
Quindi mi lasciai tutto alle spalle,
casa, lavoro, famiglia, vita privata.
Se faccio un passo indietro nel tempo
quando conducevo una vita,
chiamiamola normale,
non posso dimenticare
la depressione incalzante
per vivere una vita
che non era mai stata la mia.
E quando mi resi conto
che non stavo pi ù vivendo,
la paura attanagliava la gola
in una morsa
che non mi faceva respirare per giorni.
Beh, prima che fosse troppo tardi,
decisi di mollare tutto
e onorare le parole di Byron.
PerchéŽ, se non ho paura di morire,
ho invece molta paura di non vivere.
A bordo delle navi io faccio la fotografa.
Devo documentare
ci˜ò che accade in mare aperto,
spesso a migliaia di chilometri
dalla costa, dalla civiltˆà,
dove la legge esiste,
ma non ci sono i controlli,
quindi  è come se non ci fosse.
Ecco, Sea Shepherd
si assicura che la legge sia rispettata.
Vi parlavo prima di etica, morale, ideali,
ma la legge  è qualcosa di diverso,
è  qualcosa di concreto, tangibile,
regola le nostre vite
per ragioni pi ù che ovvie.
Ed io, in quella che  è
la mia scelta di oggi,
ho deciso, anche in nome della legge,
di salvare
ed aiutare gli abitanti
del mio adorato grande blu.
Vi racconto una cosa:
ogni anno,
nelle acque dell'Oceano Antartico,
si radunano migliaia di balene
in migrazione da nord.
Vanno a nutrirsi di krill.
È un ciclo che si ripete da millenni,
in un delicato, meraviglioso equilibrio.
Sino a quando l'essere umano
non decise che le balene
avrebbero rappresentato
una forma di sostentamento, prima,
ma di mero arricchimento economico, poi.
Tanto da cacciarle in massa,
portandole quasi all'estinzione.
CosicchŽé, nel 1986,
la Commissione Internazionale
sulla Baleneria
decretò˜ che uccidere balene è un reato.
Ma ci mise la deroga
della ricerca scientifica.
Il Giappone pone allora,
sulle fiancate delle navi,
l'enorme scritta 'Research',
presenta alla Commissione
presunti progetti di ricerca
del tutto insensati
e continua ad uccidere, indisturbato,
migliaia di balene.
Lo va a fare laddove
è più  facile cacciarle
e pi ù difficile che qualcuno
vada a disturbarlo:
il Santuario dei Cetacei,
nell'Oceano Meridionale.
Da quel 1986 al 2002 uccide,
illegalmente, pi ù di 25.000 cetacei.
Sea Shepherd non resta a guardare.
La Carta Mondiale della Natura
parla chiaro.
Ciascun cittadino del mondo
ha il diritto e il dovere,
di agire per la salvaguardia
della vita selvatica
e degli ecosistemi naturali.
Si preparano allora,
le navi e gli equipaggi
per fermare quella che è
una mattanza illegale,
irresponsabile e cruenta.
Uccidere una balena
non   è mica una cosa facile.
Un arpione esplosivo
viene conficcato nel corpo dell'animale
che, lottando disperatamente per la vita,
muore dopo una lunghissima agonia,
per diventare carne in scatola
che ormai quasi nessuno mangia,
nŽé in Giappone néŽ altrove,
o per diventare cosmetici.
Con Sea Shepherd si mettono in campo
tutte le forze, inclusa la nave stessa.
Ma l'arma più  potente
a disposizione dei pastori del mare,
è la passione dei singoli volontari,
che non si fermano
di fronte ad alcun pericolo,
pur di fermare l'ingiustizia.
Vi racconto uno dei tanti episodi,
che ho vissuto.
Mi trovavo sul ponte pi ù alto
della Bob Barker.
Dovevo, appunto,
documentare gli avvenimenti.
Ricordo quei momenti ancora
con fortissima emozione.
Mi sembrava d'essere stata catapultata
all'interno di un film d'azione,
perchéŽ, davvero,
non riuscivo a credere
a ci˜ò a cui stavo assistendo.
Essendo che la stagione di caccia
è lunga quanto l'estate antartica,
almeno 3 mesi,
la nave fabbrica giapponese
doveva accostarsi alla nave cisterna
per fare rifornimento di gasolio,
che è  un'altra attivitàˆ illecita,
in quelle acque.
E si ritorna a parlare di legge.
Ebbene, disperato,
il comandante della nave giapponese
spinge con forza
le sue 8000 tonnellate di nave
contro la nostra piccola Bob.
Ci inonda con gli idranti
di acqua gelida e salata
per impedirci di governare la nave.
Per me, nonostante il grandangolo
della macchina fotografica,
è un enorme gigante che avanza,
senza remore, contro di noi.
La Bob s'inclina
pericolosamente su un fianco.
Il cuore batte forte,
ma stranamente
non per una sensazione di pericolo,
quanto per il timore
che riescano davvero a spostarci,
che ci possano demolire
e far fallire il nostro intento.
Mi sento ripetere:
"Non mollare Peter, non mollare".
Scoprirò˜ soltanto nei giorni successivi
cosa stava accadendo
proprio sotto di me,
nel ponte di comando.
La fermezza di Peter,
il nostro giovanissimo capitano.
"Io non mi muover˜ò.
Se vuoi prendere il mio posto,
mi devi affondare".
"We need to stop this refuelling
from taking place".
(Rumori di collisione)
[Nave giapponese:] "Mayday, Mayday.
Bob Barker, we are getting rammed".
[Sea Shepherd]:"Nisshin Maru,
this is the Bob Barker,
I will not move.
You will have to sink me right here
next to the Sun Laurel.
I'm not going to move for you".
(Musica)
[Nave giapponese]
"You are destroying our boat".
[Sea Shepherd]
"Steve Irwin, they are destroying us!"
(Musica)
"Steve Irwin,
we've regained propulsion,
I have power,
I'm not backing down".
(Musica)
(Applausi)
Grazie.
Com' è andata a finire quella volta?
Eh beh, che da lassù ,
tra le lamiere spezzate della Bob
vedo quella gigantesca sagoma nera
arretrare, sconfitta.
Li stavamo mandando a casa
senza gasolio, di fatto.
Avevamo vinto la battaglia.
Quel giorno avevamo veramente
salvato le balene.
Anche quel giorno.
Vi parlavo prima di legge.
Ebbene, dopo quattro anni di processo
alla Corte Internazionale
di Giustizia dell'Aia
finalmente, arriva la sentenza.
31 marzo 2014:
'La baleneria giapponese   è una caccia
esclusivamente commerciale'.
Quella scritta Research sulle fiancate
è riconosciuta come una bugia,
uno stratagemma.
Da quel giorno,
è veto immediato al governo nipponico
di rilasciare le quote di caccia.
Ha prevalso la legge, per fortuna.
Ma ora vi porto
da un'altra parte del mondo.
Siccome ho scelto di difendere gli oceani,
dopo la stagione antartica,
mi sposto, in Nord Atlantico.
Decido di navigare attorno a questo
piccolo arcipelago di isole,
le Isole Faer Oer,
che sono una zona, di passaggio migratorio
di gruppi di grandi delfini.
Questi splendidi animali,
di una riconosciuta intelligenza
e sensibilità
e con un senso di famiglia
davvero pari al nostro,
si avventurano nei pressi delle isole,
fiduciosi e stanchi,
in cerca di riposo e di cibo.
Ma, ahimè, trovano invece la morte.
Gli isolani li uccidono in massa,
senza risparmiare nessuno.
E ci˜ò che un tempo era una caccia,
sicuramente di sussistenza,
da decenni ormai, è  soltanto
una festa, 'La Festa'.
Una cruenta, terribile mattanza,
davvero sanguinaria.
Famiglie intere che vengono sterminate.
Un patrimonio genetico
che sparisce nel nulla, per sempre.
Come lo  è ogni estinzione.
Per poi scoprire che la maggior parte
delle loro carni macellate
torna ad accumularsi sul fondo del mare,
in veri e propri cimiteri.
Ho visto
uomini di ogni etˆà, inclusi i ragazzini,
entrare nell'acqua sino alla cinta,
con il desiderio di uccidere,
con grandissima soddisfazione
quegli animali innocenti e indifesi.
Nel mentre, le loro donne
si godono lo spettacolo dalla costa,
addirittura spingono
i bimbi sulla spiaggia,
affinchéŽ assistano al massacro.
Io non potrei mai immaginare
di avere un figlio che,
con un coltellaccio in mano,
si avventura
ad uccidere terribilmente
un animale indifeso,
non per fame,
ma per il solo gusto di uccidere.
Con quali valori potrebbe crescere?
Quelle barbariche tradizioni
trovano l'appoggio
anche del governo danese,
che per contrastare noi
e chi come noi, si oppone a tutto ciò,
mette in campo addirittura
le navi da guerra, la polizia.
La scorsa estate, mi trovavo, appunto,
alle isole Faer Oer
e stavo cercando di andare a fotografare
lo sterminio
di un centinaio di globicefali,
che purtroppo non avrei pi ù
potuto aiutare.
Sono stata arrestata
ancora prima di arrivare sul posto.
Pensate, mi trovavo a bordo
di un piccolissimo gommoncino,
avevo con me solo la macchina fotografica.
Nei giorni successivi,
l'accusa, il processo,
la condanna al carcere
per aver avuto l'intenzione
di fermare la carneficina,
con una macchina fotografica,
che naturalmente mi venne sequestrata.
(Applausi)
Grazie
Credetemi, non si possono scordare
le urla
di paura e di dolore di quegli animali,
il terrore che vivono
negli ultimi lunghi momenti
della loro vita,
nel tentativo di sopravvivere,
con gli adulti che cercano
di proteggere i piccoli
e intanto il mare si colora
del rosso intenso del loro sangue.
Non si dimentica pi ù.
Vedete, balene e delfini contribuiscono
con il rimescolamento delle acque
e con il nutrimento del fitoplancton,
all'ossigenazione dell'aria
del nostro pianeta.
Proteggere quegli animali
è anche un modo
per tutelare gli oceani.
E tutelare gli oceani
è un modo per garantirci
la possibilitàˆ di vivere.
Perché  se c' è qualcosa che accomuna
tutti noi esseri viventi,
indistintamente,
indipendentemente dalla specie,
è che per vivere respiriamo.
Ed allora,
io penso,
sono fermamente convinta
che non possiamo sempre aspettarci
che sia qualcun altro ad intervenire
nel sistemare le cose,
ancor pi ù quelle che ci riguardano,
tutti, indistintamente, in tutto il mondo,
perchéŽ noi siamo gli altri
e il pianeta in cui viviamo
è la nostra casa.
Tutti, in cuor nostro,
desideriamo che le cose cambino,
per un futuro migliore.
Scommetto anche tutti voi.
Ma quanti sono davvero disposti
a cambiare un po' di se stessi?
Io ci sto provando.
E il primo passo del mio cambiamento
è stato quello
di passare da un egoistico pensiero:
"Io, qui, adesso",
al "Tutti, ovunque, sempre".
Grazie
(Applausi)